in this exercise you're going to set up
a cron job to periodically update the
announcement about the conference's that
are almost sold out you've already
written the function to create the
announcement so pretty much all you're
gonna need to do is to configure the
cron job so you configure cron jobs in
cron dot XML and this is an example of
what cron dot XML might look like as a
top-level cron entries element and then
each cron job is specified within a cron
element you must specify the path and
this is the URL that's going to run the
task invoked by the cron job you can
optionally specify a description and you
must specify a schedule the schedule
indicates how often to run the task
there's a variety of ways to set the
schedule but you must strictly follow
the syntax or the cron job won't run I
recommend checking the formats for
schedule the developer documentation
does a really nice job of describing the
syntax for the schedule and giving
examples for example you can specify it
go every 12 hours
you can specify it to go once a year
first Monday of let's say December and
then there's other ways of specifying it
anyway I really recommend you take a
look at the developer documentation for
the schedule but do bear in mind
although there's lots of flexibility in
how you specify the schedule you
actually do have to get the syntax
exactly right so you can't say every one
hour you actually have to say every one
hours the admin console on appspot for
your application has a cron jobs page
that shows you what cron jobs you've got
running I've got my cron slash set
announcement cron job running already
and I scheduled to go every one minute
and the last time it ran it had a
success if you recall the set
announcement function queries for all
conferences that are almost sold out so
if we look at the quota details you can
see that my query ops number is going up
it'll go up every minute the other thing
that's going to go up every minute is
the data store API calls so let's see so
it's 162 and that's 143 let's refresh
see what happens
if i refresh the browser and you see
that now my datastore query ops has gone
up 244 my datastore API calls have gone
up to 163 so every minute these numbers
are going to go up it's actually not a
big deal because this cron job doesn't
do a whole lot but if you have a cron
job that does a lot of reads and writes
to the datastore it is going to use up
your quota
another thing that running a cron job
every minute does is that it means your
means who App Engine application is
always in use so it now never has any
idle time which you know if your
application is in constant use by users
anyway it goes viral you're hugely
successful not a problem but when you're
developing and testing it does mean that
if you keep your cron job running
frequently it's going to keep your front
end up and you're going to use up your
instance hours so you can see here I've
already used four point six four of my
28 instance hours not a big deal but
it's something to keep an eye on after
you upload cron dot XML to App Engine it
stays there until you overwrite it with
a new cron dot XML so if you want to
disable your cron job it's not good
enough to just delete cron dot XML
completely from your app and re-upload
your app you actually have to send up a
new cron dot XML with no cron entries so
just delete the cron entry for the jobs
that you want to delete and we upload
your cron dot XML and another thing you
could do is to specify the schedule so
that only runs like once a year then
you're not going to have to worry about
quote or anything but you know why not
just go ahead and delete it anyway